ήταν προσόφελος του πολίτη είτελικά αυτόν το πολύ διαφημιζόμενον ότι έρχονται αλλαγές και θα είναι
υπρτου πολίτι ήταν ενάς μήθος γιατί βλέπουμε και από τις απλές άδειες τις πολοδομικές τις
ικιστηκές τα πάντα ότι κάπου δυσκολεύουν τα πράνομε νανα πω έτι σε μια βασική αρχή
οι καράσταση σήμεραείναι καλύτερι πό αυτή που είχαπρέχει σε πάρα πολλού τομ θέλω από ότι
και στο οικονομικό και στο γεγόνος ότι πάρα πολύμικρίνη δεν μπορούσαν ούτε τα βασικά να
δεκπεριώσουν θεωρώ ότι είμαστε σε ένα καλύτερος σημείον από αυτό πουεμαστε πριν όχι το σημείον
το οποίο όμως έπρεπε να είμαστα ή στο σηείο που θέλουμε να φτάσουμε ι αυτό
με τις άδιες παραγμοσχάρι δεν είναι τώρα που το λέω το λέγα από τότε ότι
καρατινάωψε μας δεν έπρεπε να φύγούν αυτίς οι άδειες από τους δήμς ήταν κάτι πο
διαφωνίσαμε έντονα και και λέγαμε ότι πιθάνων αυτή η συγγέντρωση αυτό το προσωπικό να πό
ευτά διαφορετικές υπηρεσίες ώσπου να βρει το το πουσολά κιτη ρέουλα ο αυτοή κατάσταση θα
έχει προβλήματα και προκαλού να πάνα δείτε ττις δρώσιες μου πριν ότι δεν είναι τώρα
που το ερθυμηίκ αλλά έχουμε να γεγονώς να πραγματικό ήταν την οοία πρέπει να δελτώσουν
εωρώ ότι αρκετα πράγματα πρέε δελτιωθούν ένα αυτόν είναι διοτήσεις που πρέπει να βρομε τον
τρόπο ν ακριβώς νανακυλήσει το πράγμα γιατί άδειες είναι και οικονομι για ναπτυξη σε ναντόπον
είναι από το σπίτι ενώ φτωχού ανθρώπου πρέπει να στεγαστεί είναι μέχρι την οικονομία σε
ένα πολείνε γαλουαθομον ώρα έχουμε πργματα να επειτύχουμε έχουμε προβλήματα αναλύσουμε αλλά έτσι αλιώς μεταλίθμη
εμείς λέγαμε και τοότε ότι δεν είναι μια στατική διαδικασία δε δε φτά τελειώσε συνεχώς
θα προκεπτιον θέματα συνερχώς θα προκεπτούν προβλήματα άρα συνεχς θα πρέπει να πελτιώνουμε αυτό πο
νομάζουμε κάθε υμερι να του πολίτη και υπήλσι στημαντικό προβλήματων ώρα είναι μια συνεχίει διαδικασί
για την οποία πρέπει να προσπαθήσουμε να ηυν πάρουμε στο σημείο τοπείο να πούμε ότι
α δεν είμαστε στο τέλιο αλλά τουλάχιστον είναι ναν υποθερτώ σημείο για να κτήσουμε πάνου
ο αντρέας βύρας κατεβαίνει κάτος στον κόσμον ακούλιπιανι τον